What is the stack feature on the right? Can I run two programs at once?
I would like to add a paid program to my night program. Can I have the right automatically repeat my night program if I'm sleeping longer than the program link?
So the stack feature on the right gives you the ability to stack one program on top of the other so it'll run so you don't have to
be aware that the first program stopped and then go into the computer and turn out the other program.
Is it easy to do? Well, I think it's easy to do, but I don't, you know, you have to be fairly, I mean, I guess somewhat computer savvy to do it.
There is a video on the course on the right course that explains the stacking feature on the right that you could do it.
We have some patients that, you know, are stacking programs and adding to their own programs and feel very comfortable with it.
You just have to feel comfortable with it. I've had people just mess up their program trying to add something into their program.
You could copy the paid program and paste it into your Monday night program and save it.
If you feel comfortable doing that, I'll ask you with how comfortable you feel doing that type of stuff.
We have some people at a very computer savvy that feel very comfortable doing that and do and and that's just fine.
So as long as you copy the entire program itself, then you can paste it into another program and just make sure it runs correctly with the version 6.4 that has been a benefit.
You know, so a lot of people that have been with through right for a long time have complained about the new orders and have complained about the new programs.
And I've always tried to soften that and one of the reasons is because I think they're new, the new program, the 6.4 is better than the 6.0 in the fact understand.
So if you're running 6.0, you don't need to upgrade to the 6.4, but one of the things that's better is it doesn't allow you to run what's called programs.
So if you have it programmed in correctly, it won't it won't run it. So it protects the machine it protects the board of the machine itself.
So I think it's a superior program to the 6.4. It's not any more powerful than the 6.0.
So if you're mainly running, you know, the programs that I have created for you, or you're running the other programs in the right program, there's no benefit to upgrading to the 6.4.
Unless you want to be doing what this person is asking is playing with stacking programs and adding things to other programs and playing with building programs.
If you, you know, it helps you not make a mistake. So it won't run a program that you accidentally have the wrong duty cycle on.
So that's what would be called a hot program.
So there are ways to do this.
We have some of those instructions on the right course.
If you want us to do that, you know, you could just contact the office and there's going to be a fee for that, but it's not that much that we can end time to your program.
Your daily program or things that you want, we have that question in request frequent thing.